- I heard this crazy story.
It's random and I have
to know if it's true.
Did you accidentally break
a First Lady's ankle?
And how does that happen, if so?
- Well, George Bush invited me
when I was the Chairman
of the President's Council on Fitness.
He would invite me always to Camp David.
This was 1991-92 when he was president.
He would invite me up there,
literally like every month.
He loved hanging out with
me and working out with me.
We do throwing horseshoe
and going running up there
and all this stuff.
And I was one time up there in the winter.
And so, he said to me, he
says, "I have this great sled,"
which was not really a
sled, it was a toboggan.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so with sleds,
you can steer the sled
with your feet.
But that one I couldn't really steer.
So, we go down the hill in the snow there.
He's sitting behind me
and he says, "You steer."
And I did not know how to steer.
So, I mean, just going faster and faster
and all of a sudden, we're
approaching this tree
and all of a sudden Barbara
comes up behind the tree
and then we just ran into her leg.
And so, poor Barbara Bush,
she was like, she had to go
to the hospital afterwards.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- She had a sprained leg
and she got a cast on it
and the whole thing like that.
But I have to say that they
were very gracious about it
and the way that they took it.
And I apologized.
I said, "I feel really bad."
- [Kelly] Nobody has this story.
That's incredible.
- [Arnold] She was a wonderful First Lady.
- Wow.